all right well speaking of uh of crying
let's let's let's advance to uh the next
story in this saga which is it's all
it's all somewhat related but this is a
little bit different we have this from
politico
twitter's top lawyer reassures staff and
cries
during meeting about musk takeover
vijaya gaday a key executive involved in
decisions to remove former president
donald trump and banned political
advertising expressed uncertainty about
the future of the platform i'll i'm not
going to gloat over someone crying um i
think it's a good example nonetheless of
the problems this company has elon musk
did not do anything
the deal's not even done
all that's happened is they've they've
signed the document saying we're gonna
we're gonna have a deal for all we know
doesn't go through for some reason
side note in the event the deal doesn't
go through twitter has to pay elon musk
one billion dollars okay if elon musk
screws up the deal he's gonna pay them
one billion dollars but i doubt that's
going to happen so
if the shareholders vote no on this deal
they have elon cornered these these this
company this is incredible let me just
break this down
elon makes the offer shortly before
their first quarter earnings report in
which the revenue is likely going to
show bad bad quarter so the stock will
go down elon musk offers them a premium
if they reject that and the stock goes
down now they're liable to the
shareholders for not accepting something
they they knew was it was a good deal
in the deal they agree to a one million
a one billion dollar breakup clause if
the shareholders vote no elon musk gets
a free billion dollars so now the
shareholders are like if we don't vote
for this not only are we likely going to
see the stock plummet but we're going to
be out the company will be at a billion
dollars causing it to plummet even more
elon won then 4d chess if there's stock
plummets he just gets a bunch of robin
hood accounts buys it up anyway boom
elon wins he gets he gets all of their
toilet paper shares but so for those of
you may be familiar vagi is the woman
who was on the joe rogan experience with
me and jack dorsey
and she's breaking down and crying
many people pointed out
the reason she was on the show is she is
actually the person behind everything
that's been happening at twitter in
terms of all the wokeness the political
manipulation it's her
she's the one and now she's crying over
this
look i'm not here to gloat with the
crying you want to make fun of her for
crying and laugh about it fine i'll just
point out the crying shows
they've no they know they've lost this
is a major moment
well reminds me of when the google
employees had the their big open house
or the
the big meeting after trump won and they
were all crying and and worried and it
the the tremendous angst that they
expressed about
their role in allowing trump to win and
defeat hillary clinton and
we saw them respond and react what i'm
wondering about is what's going to
happen
in the twitter world at the business
because there's going to be a resistance
there i think to what elon musk wants to
do the culture is so ingrained with the
wokeness there from the bottom and the
top and we saw with this with the
attorney crying here how do you say her
name again vijaya gaday
i can't try that one that's too hard for
me but um
it's an example of what he's gonna face
with the personnel there and the
wokeness and he's going to face a
resistance like president trump faced
with the administrative state well then
the first thing you do is fire vagina
and then everyone else is going well
that's what trump should have done with
a lot of people in the first place he
should have terminated some of these
people and he loves saying you're fired
it's shocking that he didn't but there's
civil there's civil protections on many
of the government employees right
on some of them but there were a lot of
them in the national security staff we
should have let a lot of people go right
away we had a lot of political
appointees that were allowed to hang on
elon elon musk can walk in and say
you're fired yes he owns it outright
it's remarkable seeing some of these
people they really don't understand
anything about work or companies because
some of these lefties are like elon musk
is you know i'm losing a bunch of
followers elon musk is causing a lot of
damage to the shareholders and it's just
like you realize he bought the company
100 there's no shareholders anymore it's
just him
he's happy with it i hope he'll
understand that if you're crying about
the new boss that's coming in he's gonna
fire you if he finds that no yeah that's
exactly i was just thinking that it's
remarkable how dumb and
even really unemployable these people
are outside of any kind of environment
where they're being catered to by their
higher ups the fact that somebody takes
over to the company that you're working
for and you immediately start publicly
trash talking them is so ridiculous well
they've never had another job in their
lives well what their attitude should be
and i i grew up in the military and i
matured through learning how to be a
team player and a leader and work for
people and we have changes of command
and we have changes of administrations
that we had to respond to over the years
what your job is is to
find out where the boss wants to go help
them get there okay if there are
problems in his way identify what those
problems are and help mitigate those
give them a pathway you're supposed to
be part of a team and if you're not
going to row the oars in the direction
that the new boss wants to go you have
an obligation to resign
sheamus
this probably is their first job yeah
that's what i'm saying a lot of these
people probably got masters or something
got out of college at 24 and then
applied it twitter it's the first place
they've ever worked they probably view
twitter as a home yeah something like
that well and i've sort of joked about
this in the past but it's part of why we
live in such a bizarre world where
conservative people are afraid to voice
their own opinions and signal the fact
that they're on the right and left-wing
people are very comfortable doing so at
their jobs because when you state you're
a left-wing individual of this brand of
progressivism all you're doing is
advertising the fact that you're
unemployable
and yet it seems as if employers are
fine like what are you gonna do if you
get rid of all the conservatives fire
everyone who shows up on time and fire
everyone who cares about doing the job
fire everyone who doesn't have an
entitlement complex i'm pretty sure
political protections political
discrimination only exists in washington
dc for the most part i mean maybe
there's some smaller jurisdictions but
dc protects political affiliation as a
protected class makes sense if you're
forced to go live in dc at least
partially because you're in congress or
whatever having someone say we don't
serve republicans is a huge problem
outside of there i'm pretty sure
if you went to a company and said that
you are a leftist they could be like
we're not hiring you or if you were in
the middle of your job and said you were
a leftist or a conservative they could
be like you're fired for that reason
yeah well it's an interesting point too
because you could have uh a particular
business that has to service a market so
for example if you were doing something
like producing conservative content you
probably wouldn't want to hire left-wing
people and it would be bizarre if there
was a law requiring you to do so
i don't think that hiring anybody that's
political makes sense if someone comes
in and they're like i identify
get out identity politics
well hold on there gender identity is
protected
that's that's it's pretty insane in my
opinion sometimes weird thing to bring
up a job interview decide what your
gender is and then have that protected
is insane i understand immutable
characteristics that you didn't choose
but
if it's gender that you get to pick
that's weird and in new york gender
identity is is described in law as
self-expression
yeah which self-expression is not that's
the weak defies corporate logic we've
talked about this it's uh
there is no black and white approach to
upholding civil rights it's always a
gradient because everything is connected
to everything else there's this idea
that exists among many traditional or
classical liberals
where it's like if we enshrine in law
that men and women shall be treated
equally we are done we've done it we
have equal rights and then someone says
okay they're treated equally what does
that mean
well it means you can't discriminate
against them based on you know their
biological sex it's like okay well this
bathroom says women only you mean i'm
not allowed to go in it because i'm
biologically male well that's
discriminating isn't it it literally is
in law in which case then you have
judges so i'd say okay well there's an
exception an exemption in that one like
we we didn't mean that you didn't what
happens is a generation goes by and
people don't know what you actually
meant all that matters is what's written
down in law and you get textualists who
then just say and it says you can't do
it that's where we're at now the 1964
civil rights act meant some very obvious
things
provide service to people don't kick
them out because of these
characteristics now it's
it's being challenged across the board
so what ends up happening is
you had that uh i think was a supreme
court case where they tried arguing that
i think this is what happened right
gender identity was considered the same
thing as sexuality in some court case
yes that's correct and
they're not but the court said so and so
i i think that's what brought us to
where we are now one thing led to
another because everything is
interconnected it's not a slippery slope
it's just dominoes falling over the next
thing that's going to happen is in new
york where they say
gender identity is just self-expression
well they have to do that because what
are they really protecting when they
protect gender identity if you are
biologically male and want to wear a
dress and call yourself susan that's
what they're protecting
but what's the difference between
calling yourself susan in a dress and
calling yourself volcipheron herald of
the winter mists while wearing a fursuit
literally nothing except for the
cultural interpretation but if a judge
can say one set of clothing is protected
and another isn't based on his personal
interpretation then you're gonna you're
gonna get a whole bunch of challenges
now judges are supposed to interpret the
law but the next step will be in 20
years they're going to say the law says
my self-expression
that means i want to go to work as
volcipheron you think it's going to take
a whole 20 years for that no no no not
at all yeah
but um but actually i think it might be
reversing i mean look at what's going on
with twitter these people are crying
they've lost
this this mission that they've been on
well i'm not sure they've lost yet no i
mean i mean this portion they're losing
there's good news okay and i think we
have good reason to be hopeful for what
twitter could become
and it was really quite bad okay and
it wasn't doing that well as a business
was it
five billion dollars in revenues
it wasn't profitable
113 million active followers
well they i think they got up to 212
million at one time yeah at one time but
the latest according to epoch times is
113 million if that's true their stock
was about to plummet right and so to ten
bucks the people that work for twitter
should look at elon musk as a savior
because the business model was not
working the way these guys had been
running it i just did some math at 7 500
plus employees imagining that they're
making 75 000 a year they're probably
making more than that it's more than
half a billion dollars a year in just an
employee salaries like that's way way
way too much for a company that's only
pulling in five billion i mean
i guess a fifth of your op a fifth of
your revenue is
is i don't i haven't worked at enough
companies to know if that's
that just sounds like way too much uh
expenditure on employees and for a
company that can send its people remote
it doesn't make
i want to look at the business plan i
want to just say uh when we're talking
about jobs i think vijaya got his job is
not long for this world
sagar and jetty says
vijaya gaday the top censorship advocate
at twitter
who famously gaslet the world on joe
rogan's podcast and censored the hunter
biden laptop story is very upset about
the elon musk takeover elon musk
responded suspending the twitter account
of a major news organization for
publishing a truthful story was
obviously incredibly inappropriate
absolutely i can't imagine elon musk as
the owner of this company is going to go
in there and be like i'm going to keep
this person in fact he's probably going
to go in there and say you caused the
bulk of the problem so thank you for
your time and you are free to go
so derek i'm curious as someone who has
worked in the the white house and some
pretty high levels within government how
is social media viewed or discussed at
that level if at all
that's a good question it is discussed a
lot and
how to navigate it if you're in the
trump white house
the stories the media
and the way
big media mainstream media integrated
itself with the narratives of social
media and we see today that you know cnn
was actively coordinating with
you know people that were behind the
russia hoax to get the narrative right
and to expand on it
you know we worried about it a lot most
of us were looking at the social media
impact
as a as a national level of influence
for overseas because i don't mostly in
the foreign policy world and what we
could learn from social media from
looking at social media accounts in
ukraine or the middle east or what isis
was posting so there's different ways of
looking at it
from my perspective it was as an
intelligence tool to get insights into
into groups organizations and people
do you think this is part of why the
taliban was allowed to be on twitter
while trump was banned well
you look at and homey and
leaders of the codes force being on
twitter
and
the issues that they were taken and what
they were calling for violence against
israel violence against other people
calling out for the death of president
trump
and they were not shut down they were
not banned so the hypocrisy of the
leadership of twitter and when they talk
about values and threats of violence
they never followed up
their words with actions
in exercising their leadership in an
unbiased way they never did and that's
part of the reason they've had so many
problems and they lost so many followers
from 214 million to 113 active thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there